היי וברוכים השבים לסדרת הקורס Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
שמי Victoria Lipinska ובסרטון הזה נצלול לתוך איך לייצג
בעיית VQE נתונה בצורה שהמחשב הקוונטי מבין.
בדרך כלל, בעיית כימיה קוונטית מבוטאת במונחים של אנרגיות
של המערכת.
אנחנו מתייחסים לאופרטור שמתאר את האנרגיות האלה בשם ה-Hamiltonian.
קודם כל, צריך לכמת אותו.
כלומר לבטא אותו בשפה של כימיה קוונטית,
שנקראת רשמית כימות שני.
אם ה-Hamiltonian מתאר אינטראקציות פרמיוניות, למשל,
אנרגיה של אלקטרונים ב-spin orbitals, אנחנו מתייחסים לזה
כ-Hamiltonian פרמיוני, וזה יהיה נקודת ההתחלה שלנו היום.
ל-qubits, לעומת זאת, יש שפה משלהם.
האופרטורים בעולם ה-qubit מתוארים על ידי אופרטורי Pauli.
אז המיקוד שלנו פה הוא לבטא את האופרטורים הפרמיוניים
במונחים של אופרטורי qubit.
יש התאמה פשוטה אחד-לאחד בין
מצבי האפס והאחד של פרמיונים ו-qubits.
אז המיפוי בין המצבים הוא גם ישיר למדי.
אבל המיפוי של האופרטורים הוא קצת יותר מורכב.
אבל Hamiltonians פרמיוניים מבוטאים עם אופרטורי יצירה
והשמדה.
אז המשימה שלנו היא להקל על המחשב הקוונטי להבין
את ה-Hamiltonian.
נשתמש בכלים מתמטיים כדי למפות Hamiltonian פרמיוני
ל-Hamiltonian של qubit עם gates.
אז במילים אחרות, אנחנו נתרגם בין
שפת הכימיה הקוונטית לשפת המחשוב הקוונטי.
דמיינו שתי שרשראות, אחת עם פרמיונים,
כלומר שפת הכימיה הקוונטית.
ואחת עם qubits, כלומר שפת המחשוב הקוונטי.
במבט ראשון, המיפוי נראה ישיר, נכון?
בשני המקרים, אנחנו רואים מערכות עם שני רמות.
בפרמיונים, יש לנו או פרמיון אחד במצב
או בכלל אין פרמיון.
ובשביל qubits, יש לנו או מצב 0 או מצב 1.
אבל זה יותר מורכב מזה.
ההבדל בין שרשרת של qubits לשרשרת של פרמיונים
הוא משהו מאוד בסיסי בפיזיקה: מה שאנחנו קוראים לו סימטריית החלפה.
שני פרמיונים לעולם לא יכולים לתפוס את אותו מצב.
אבל בשרשרת של qubits, זה לגמרי שונה.
שני qubits יכולים להיות באותו מצב,
כי qubit הוא לא פרמיון.
עכשיו צריך למצוא דרך לתרגם בין שתי השרשראות.
כבר ב-1928, שני חוקרים, Jordan ו-Wigner,
הראו שאופרטורים פרמיוניים לכל השרשרת
ניתן לייצג במדויק במונחים של אופרטורי qubit.
זה המיפוי הכי ישיר למחשב קוונטי.
למשל, אפשר להשתמש בזה כדי למפות תפיסה
של orbital לסיבוב של qubit אחד.
בפועל, המיפוי הזה עבור Hamiltonian מניב סכום משוקלל של אופרטורי Pauli.
זה עובדה מאוד חשובה, שאני רוצה שתזכרו,
ונחזור לזה במודול הבא שבו נדבר
על איך circuits וריאציוניים מורצים על המחשב הקוונטי.
המיפוי שלמעלה אומר שאם היה לנו, למשל,
14 אופרטורים פרמיוניים, נמפה את הבעיה ל-14 qubits.
למזלנו, קיימות דרכים חכמות להפחית את מספר ה-qubits
ולהשתמש בפחות משאבים קוונטיים כדי לקבל ביצועים טובים יותר מהמחשב הקוונטי.
בדרך כלל, במערכת מולקולרית, נדע
כמה סימטריות פיזיקליות של ה-Hamiltonian,
לדוגמה, המספר הכולל של האלקטרונים קבוע.
המידע הזה אפשר להשתמש בו כדי להקטין את גודל הבעיה
מבלי לאבד מידע רלוונטי.
אנחנו קוראים לטכניקה הזאת הפחתת המרחב הפעיל.
זה מאפשר הפחתת מספר המשאבים, כלומר מספר ה-qubits,
לפני מיפוי ה-qubit כמו טרנספורמציית Jordan-Wigner.
השלב הזה מחשב Hamiltonian אפקטיבי
ומאפשר לנו להשתמש בפחות qubits כתוצאה מכך.
בדוגמה שלנו עם 14 orbitals,
הטכניקה הזאת מפחיתה את מספר ה-qubits לשישה בלבד.
עכשיו אנחנו יכולים ללכת אפילו יותר רחוק עם ההפחתות האלה.
אנחנו יכולים להשתמש במיפויים שונים,
שהם קצת יותר מורכבים מ-Jordan-Wigner.
הדוגמה הכי נפוצה היא מיפוי הפריטי.
מיפוי הפריטי לא ממפה תפיסה של orbitals על ה-qubits,
אלא את הפריטי של orbitals על qubits בודדים.
לא נכנס לפרטים המתמטיים כאן,
אבל מה שחשוב לדעת הוא שהמיפוי הזה מכיל
עודפויות שאפשר לנצל כדי להסיר עוד שני qubits.
לכן, הדוגמה שלנו עם 14 orbitals, מצטמצמת מ-14 qubits
ל-6 qubits עם הפחתת המרחב הפעיל ואז ל-4 qubits
עם הפחתת שני ה-qubits במיפוי הפריטי.
בואו נזכיר בקצרה עוד טרנספורמציה אחת.
מיפוי נפוץ נוסף בין הייצוג הפרמיוני
לייצוג qubit הוא טרנספורמציית Bravyi-Kitaev.
טרנספורמציית Bravyi-Kitaev משתמשת ב-qubits כדי לקודד את המידע
על מספר התפיסה ועל הפריטי של המצב הקוונטי.
טרנספורמציית Bravyi-Kitaev משלבת מידע על מספר תפיסה ופריטי
עבור בסיס orbital מולקולרי בגודל N,
שוב משתמשים ב-N qubits.
אבל המידע השמור בתוך כל qubit
משתנה עכשיו בהתאם לאיזה qubit זה.
כלומר כאשר האינדקס של ה-qubit הוא זוגי,
הוא מאחסן את מספר התפיסה של ה-orbital המתאים
כמו במיפוי Jordan-Wigner.
כאשר אינדקס ה-qubit הוא אי-זוגי, ה-qubit מאחסן פריטי של
קבוצת מספרי תפיסה מסוימת. טרנספורמציית Bravyi-Kitaev היא הכי יעילה
כאשר מספר ה-qubits מתקרב לחזקה של שתיים.
מיפוי Bravyi-Kitaev משלב את היתרונות של Jordan-Wigner
ושל טרנספורמציות הפריטי.
הוא מפחית את מספר ה-qubits שכל איבר Hamiltonian פועל עליהם,
זה חשוב לסימולציה קוונטית כי איברים
שפועלים על מספר גדול של qubits ב-Hamiltonian
דורשים circuits ארוכים יותר לסימולציה שלהם.
המשמעות היא שעומק ה-circuit
מצטמצם עם טרנספורמציית Bravyi-Kitaev ובאופן כללי
אנחנו יכולים לקבל תוצאות טובות יותר עם החומרה.
זו שיפור על טרנספורמציית Jordan-Wigner
שמניבה Hamiltonian של qubit מסדר N.
אז, בסרטון הזה בדקנו שיטות למיפוי
Hamiltonian פרמיוני ל-Hamiltonian של qubit.
בסרטון הבא נראה איך לבחור בצורה הטובה ביותר את המצב
וצורה וריאציונית או circuit.
נתראה שם.